one of the hardest things about making
your dream or your small business or
your blog or whatever it's just doing it
taking that first step can often be the
only thing standing in your way because
once you start getting it done the
momentum just carries you forward
there's no doubt that taking that first
step can be terrifying I get it I really
do but I also have to wonder would you
be so afraid if you knew no one was
watching see I think what really scares
people is not fear of failure but fear
of feeling in front of someone who
matters like your mom or dad your best
friend a sibling a mentor a spouse none
of us wants to disappoint someone we
admire but if you want to be an
entrepreneur if that's what you really
really want you cannot care about what
other people think of you
not even your parents I won't lock it
don't criticize you they will say mean
things leave even equal things often
because they're jealous that you have
the guts to get out there and do your
thing or because they
love you very much and are scared to you
and that's okay if you truly trust and
believe in yourself you will learn to
ignore them and they will learn to
accept your decision
and if you fail on people laugh with you
they're not worth your time
ignore them if feels will Denis back
think about whose opinion matters the
most to you and then sit down with that
person or those people face-to-face and
this is what you say I'm about to do
this thing and the only reason I haven't
yet is because I don't want to let you
down this is a long journey and I know
I'm gonna make it in the end
but I need to know that if I stumble you
won't think less of me
or turn away because that would crush me
anyone with heart would be touched by
such vulnerability and show of respect
who wouldn't be honored to learn that
his or her opinion meant that much of
you changes are good they'll promise to
have your back and hopefully that's all
you'll need to take the next step you
want to surround yourself with people
who are going to stand by you and
encourage you to get back up not keep
you down
you